comment allez-vous 2021 quelles sont vos
bonnes résolutions
quand on vous allez vous mettre au sport
ça tombe bien vu le thème de la vidéo
écoutez moi janvier 2018 je décide de
mettre au sport je vais à la salle pour
la première fois de ma vie tout se passe
bien c'est cool c'est agréable mais plus
le temps passe et plus j'ai la flemme
pas d'être à la salle est de faire du
sport mais d'aller à la salle le
de trajet pour y aller pour rentrer
parce que la salle la plus proche est là
15 minutes de motos de chez moi alors en
2020 et le confinement a beaucoup aidés
évidemment je me suis mis à faire du
sport de chez moi et un nouveau
champ des possibles c'est offert à moi
il vous faut juste le sol de chez vous
et votre corps est un petit tapis pour
éviter la de la voile à l'asnl à la
dureté de votre sol d'ailleurs avec mon
code promo il y en a c'est faux aucun on
m'avait toujours dit que ce qu'il
voulait remettre au sport vraiment le
seul moyen de vraiment s'y mettre c'est
de prendre un abonnement à la salle de
sport bla bla bla c'est faux vous vous
sentez seul à la salle donc vous voulez
nous ramener là bas mais c'est pas un
impératif et depuis j'en fais depuis
chez moi je suis tellement plus heureux
plus épanouie et regarder comme ça a
porté ses fruits
regardez à quel point j'ai pris du
muscle ça se voie entre une vidéo de fin
2019 et une vidéo de fin 2020 ça se voit
bref aujourd'hui on va regarder des
trucs qui nous rappelle cette fameuse
époque on pouvait aller à la salle de
sport dans une salle de sport il se
passe trop de choses incroyables et la
danse qu'on va regarder se passe encore
plus de choses parce que vous savez
c'est les salles aux états unis qui sont
genre immense qui font genre mille
mètres carrés et du coup l'abonnement il
est grave pas cher et donc tu as
beaucoup de gens qui vont là bas pour
faire du sport mais qui connaissent pas
du tout le sport pas du tout les
mouvements pas du tout les machines et
ça donne lieu à des trucs assez marrant
bref c'est parti les chaussettes de cet
homme à la gym gars qui a pas des jambes
si fine que ça il fait genre mais c'est
pas choquant quoi les gars les jambes
cet exo la la la presse je peux pas je
les fais trois fois j'étais abattu je
pouvais plus marcher je bomber le torse
pour faire genre tout allait bien tout
le monde voyait que ça allait pas la
honte c'est la honte c'est imbécile à la
salle de sport qu'est ce qu'il a fait il
prend très cher dans le titre qu'est ce
qu'il a fait
[Musique]
aux ados excusez moi mais il a cru
c'était des poids jetables calme-toi
friot il a parmi les poids et se bat
sans avoir vomi les poires il se fait
rattraper par un mail qui lui dit range
tes poids sdp il y va chialer marge de
8,1 au oui tu marches invités après
avoir fait ça moi ça me rend dingue
parce que je fais partie de la team qui
austro pas dire aux gars qui vient de
commettre une incivilité est est mignon
mais tu va m'être comporté maintenant
moi vraiment j'ai pas envie de vivre ce
malaise social que représente le fait
d'aller voir un mec et de l'engueuler
touché c'est horrible je peux pas les
gars je suis incapable
normalement tu te remets en question tu
vois quand mais en face des choses lui
il fait genre il part il est horrible ce
mec c'est triste c'est triste mais cool
à la fois c'est vachement bizarre bah
franchement ça ne dérangerait pas elle
tue la salle de sport l'inta un banc et
vous tous les poids du monde pour toi
tout seul c'est un peu plus discret tu
te fais un peu moins jugé j'apprécie mon
tapis de course simule une course dans
skyrim
c'est la pire chose
du coup tu as envie de jouer à skyrim
donc des kurtas et en situant entre pour
jouer c'est quelque chose me fait
m'étais jamais ça sur le tapis comme ça
moi je suis mort ah non ça c'est des
vidéos de gens qui font mal l'exercice
et à des gens plutôt que d'aller leur
expliquer les films et nous regardent
ces vidéos là en faisant le tac ruth
était dans une attraction à disneyland
mais tu vas te péter le dollar vous
remarquerez la personne a filmé dans un
miroir pour passer à griller quelle
fourberie 3 les gens qui font mal les
exos ça me fait un nom aux non non c'est
trop triste mais dites lui dit lui qu'il
ne doit pas servir de l'élan de son
corps pour monter et doit servir
uniquement des bras quitte à faire moins
de traction au début quand j'allais à la
salle et même encore un peu maintenant
des fois je mets des poids trop lourd
parigot ouais je vous le dis je sais que
c'est trop long mais j'ai de lego et
quelquefois ya des mecs qui sont venus
qui m'ont dit salut frérot tu devrais
mettre un tout petit peu moins lourd
comme ça tu fais mieux le geste et du
coup tu travailles mieux la zone et où
et franchement j'ai bien pris ça a été
très pratique
mon ego était brisée pendant trois
semaines voient la cgil est vraiment
bien pris encore un mais deux films dans
le miroir vous êtes malin ce
qu'ils jugent fort les autres vous êtes
malin en plus c'est horrible
mais qu'est-ce qui fait il se muscle
coup j'en perds ma webcam attendait mais
ce qui l'a mis sur sa tête c'est pas une
ceinture de squats ou t'accrocher un
poids pendant tu fais tes squat
peut-être qu'on juge un peu vite et
c'est vraiment un exo qui existent mais
vu le mouvement qui fait j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est pas bon du tout
pour ton corps quand les gens qui font
du crossfit vont dans une salle normal
mais arrêtez de faire n'importe quoi
avec cette machine merde mais qu'est ce
qu'ils foutent
mange le sol en plus regardé le mec ça
doit être trop dur d'avoir une salle de
sport et voir des gens faire ça avec tes
machine s'est tu dois dire mais
mais j'ai vraiment fait la mauvaise
activités quoi c'est ce terrible qu'est
ce qui fait aulas mais mec tu achètes
d'allevard ils font exprès je vais pas
le juger il se peut que j'ai fait ça
pendant un confinement sur mon canapé
alors il n'a pas cassé mais c'est
c'était très humiliant n'était pas fait
pour le coc vide il a tout compliqué les
gars juge pas les gens qui font ces de
l'haltérophilie je crois ça s'appelle le
tout coûte à une barre avec des poils
mégalo et tu fais ça et c'était mon
l'antenne ceinture tout le corps à lui
seul se brise tu n'as pas cette ceinture
comme maintenir tout et bien sachez que
vous m'offrez sur des vaches mans et je
m'inquiète pour deux choses dans la vie
natsu et vous je vous jure que vous
faites votre truc je suis pas bien quoi
j'ai peur vous blessez salle à chaque
fois qu'est ce qui se passe ou à l'huile
et au à lui champion lui les terres
[Musique]
qu'esquisser annoncé un contorsionniste
il va faire un truc bizarre
on va tous essayer d'accord je fête du
pain d'épicés impossible qu'est ce que
c'est que cette merde je ne comprends
pas le corps de ce mec sa mère l'a foutu
en vrac quoi elle a assemblé au pif jet
ski ou c'est qu'il fait le mouvement
avec un poids en plus c'est à dire cette
position horrible lui il soutient fois
tranquillement il fait ça quel enfer
s'il vous plaît rangez vos poids assez
un cauchemar at-il boîtier va faire un
avc s'il voit sa mamelle à frérot ils
abusent c'est incroyable y en a pas un
qui arrange et un poids assez incroyable
c'est quoi cette salle c'est des animaux
la sécu c'est moi mais c'est n'importe
quoi au ces les femmes un mec qui
m'impressionne et dont je m'inquiète
beaucoup je me prépare appelé
l'ambulance nova oui un blessé dans la
salle est encore nettement la sa chute
elle est sobre il a pu contrôler un peu
c'est pas tomber sur ses jambes mais les
mecs qui le font au level des fois ils
font ça et ça tourne sur leurs cuisses
c'est terrible tu sors de ça après tu
peux faire des haltères dans ce sens là
avec tes bras c'est ouf d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui est arrivé à l'os
il a eu un accident comme ça et en
sortant de là ils pouvaient faire des
haltères dans ce sens là avec ses bras
c'est dingue
les gars aider le il a 70 ans et s'est
remis au sport
donnez lui déconseille moi des fois je
me suis fait engueuler parce que je
faisais pas le mouvement entièrement lui
il fait le mouvement avec une autre
partie de son corps c'est un autre level
on voit qu'ils souffrent je suis presque
seul c'est plus dur de le faire comme ça
que le faire comme ça je suis presque
sûr non non j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
elle a pété la vitre elle a pété lavit
elle a exposé un an non au nom mignotte
cette réaction
ll a dû rejoindre la team au sport à la
maison après ça après avoir été viré de
sa salle de sport les gens s'inquiètent
vous pétez des vitres ensuite vous avez
ont arrêté sa souplesse et un truc de
cirque ça la planche sur une boule
qu'est ce qu'elle fait qu'est ce qu'elle
fait on a même est derrière mais qu'est
ce qu'elle veut faire au vilain tour à
je m'inquiète pour elle c'est une
personne à risque
elle est adorable j'adore voir des gens
âgés faire du sport d'ailleurs il ya un
truc que les vieux ils font que j'adore
c'est courir avec des pois dans les
mains j'espère que commencera vieux on
se croisera pendant ce genre de footing
vous et moi et que les poids lourds deux
roues seront plus sûrs que les vôtres
facile à faire ça facile ça ça je sais
faire ça
non mais c'est quoi ce mec oui mais en
râlant dessus ça va gros mégalo d'accord
il creux d exercer sur mesure quoi les
exercices basiques ne lui font plus
excuses nouveau je veux pas juste la
levée je vais faire comme si c'était une
rame pas mais quelle montagne de muscles
fait croquer les autres un peu merde
la laverie de mon quartier à installer
des équipements de muscu que tu peux
utiliser quand attend la fin de ta
machine
alors ça c'est une très bonne idée de
mettre des trucs dans des endroits où
les gens de façon n'aura d'autre à faire
que d'attendre j'avais bien aimé
d'ailleurs l'initiative de mettre des
pianos dans les deux gars comme ça un
lieu où la définition c'est j'attends et
devrait mettre à côté du piano une
petite salle de sport comme ça quand tu
attends ton train c'est plus actes en
temps c'est un truc un peu assez bien ça
non mais c'est encore la même machine
les gars j'en peux plus personne n'a
compris cette machine c'est ouf
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui fait ce batteur il est
complètement soukra 15 pas possible
attendez mais ça fait deux personnes qui
font la même chose là instinctivement et
un truc chez l'humain il ya vraiment des
gens ils ont envie de faire ça avec
cette machine
non ça se trouve parmi ceux qui gardent
y en as genre 3 il y en a peut-être
genre 3 confessa la preuve est là ils
deviennent rouges écoles mais regarde
cette vidéo entre amis ils sont des
gosses souligner le fait qu'ils sont
rouges du coup la thèse amis sont en
train de regarder et tu vas devoir
s'expliquer avec eux je suis partie le
moins statistiquement vu le nombre de
gens qui regardent cette vidéo il ya
forcément masse gens qu'on fait des
dingueries à la salle de sport dit nous
on veut savoir où vous jugera pas
évidemment quand vous jugera vous aurez
même film et si on avait pu mec c'est
encore la même machine ça me rend dingue
ça rentre à 9h en banque il est possédé
la session john qui se manifestent mais
je peux les regarder encore et encore ça
me fascine ça me rappelle l'exercice la
cette fameuse scène horrible lui pour le
coup ça représente vraiment aucun effort
de faire ça c'est zéro il ya réel qui
travaillent à part évité l'exercice tu
fais rien du tout vrai haut je fais mon
work out
[Musique]
c'est dingue il limite vraiment c'est un
hasard ou ces genres à mover réputé dans
le game du lézard c'est fou je pense
c'est une de coïncidence mais
c'est très drôle à voir
ah ça c'est le chien qui imitent les
humains qui font du sport j'adore à aa
j'adore ma date où il fait passer un
mois il vient il met sa langue umit
comme ça dans mon oreille quand je suis
en train de faire la planche ça rend
l'exercice encore plus difficile je cède
avant les deux minutes je remets la
faute sur lui finalement il met bien et
bah écoutez j'ai pris plaisir à voir
tout ça à tel point que là je vais me
faire une petite séance de sport je vous
jure c'est vrai je vais faire deux trois
traction je vais renforcer ces horribles
club que j'ai sur les mains un plaisir
chez sûr parmi vous il y en a plein de
1021 qui ont pris la résolution de se
mettre au sport d'un côté c'est une
bonne résolution et sans même parler de
transformation physique
psychologiquement en tant que gars qui
vient de le vivre ça fait vraiment du
bien et ce qui fait du bien aussi c'est
de voir le progrès au fil des séances
voir ton corps qui évolue qui s'adapte
c'est assez ouvre évidemment ne filmez
pas les gens à la salle allait plutôt
les aider au pire fait une vidéo sur
leur gueule directement mais voilà les
films je m'en veux un peu mais en même
temps c'est intéressant de voir ça allez
bonne séance à tous j'ai vu vraiment je
sais pas une blague a très vite merci à
vous regarder
[Musique]